LEAVES THE WHITE HOUSE FOR
CAMP DAVID.
WE WILL GET YOU TO YOU AS SOON
AS WE CAN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP OWNS A PRETTY
DECENT CHUNK OF PROPERTY IN
FLORIDA AND DORIAN COULD MAKE
LANDFALL RIGHT AROUND HIS
MAR-A-LAGO ESTATE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS CANCELED A
PLANNED OVERSEAS STATE TO TRACK
THE STORM, BUT HE IS STILL
TAKING CONSIDERABLE GRIEF,
POLITICAL SNIPING EVEN BEFORE
THE STORM LANDS.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS HAS THAT FOR THE
STORY TONIGHT.
>> AS DORIAN CONTINUES ITS
RELENTLESS MARCH TOWARDS A
FLORIDA COAST, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TWEETING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS FULLY PREPARED FOR WHAT LIES
AHEAD.
>> WE HAVE THE BEST PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD READY AND GOING TO
HELP PEOPLE SHIPPING FOOD,
SHIPPING WATER BUT IT MAY BE YOU
ARE GOING TO EVACUATE.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
WE ARE WAITING.
IT DOES SEEM ALMOST CERTAIN IT'S
HITTING DEAD CENTER.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S CRITICS
COMPARING HIS CONCERN FOR
FLORIDA WITH WHAT THEY SAY WAS
HIS LACK OF IT WHEN THE STORM
WAS TAKING DIRECT AIM AT
PUERTO RICO.
>> PART OF IT IS FLORIDA COULD
BE A SWING STATE IN 2020.
PART OF IT IS FLORIDA IS NOT AN
ISLAND FULL OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> THREE DAYS AGO,
PRESIDENT TRUMP APPEARED ANNOYED
THAT DORIAN WAS EYEBALLING
PUERTO RICO, WOW, GET ANOTHER
STORM HITTING PUERTO RICO, WILL
IT EVER AND MET?
PUERTO RICO WAS ONE OF THE MOST
CORRUPT PLACES ON EARTH.
AT THE SAME TIME, FEMA WAS WELL
PREPARED FOR A DIRECT HIT ON THE
ISLAND, STOCKING MULTIPLE
WAREHOUSES WITH RELIEF SUPPLIES.
DEMOCRATS WERE FOCUSED ON WHAT
THE PRESIDENT SAID, NOT WHAT HE
DID.
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T VIEW
PUERTO RICO AS PART OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HE DOESN'T VIEW PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T VOTE FOR HIM AS IMPORTAN
IMPORTANT, AND HE DOESN'T VIEW
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T WHITE AS
IMPORTANT AS EVERYONE ELSE.
>> DEMOCRATS ALSO CRITICIZED THE
PRESIDENT FOR GIVING THE GREEN
LIGHT TO DIVERTING FUNDS FROM
ONE OF FEMA'S DISASTER RELIEF
ACCOUNTS TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS
ON THE BORDER.
FEMA INSISTS IT STILL HAS PLENTY
OF MONEY TO ADDRESS STORMS AND
IS ALREADY MOBILIZED AN
AGGRESSIVE RESPONSE TO DORIAN.
FLORIDA'S DEMOCRATIC AGRICULTURE
SAYING THE PRESIDENT MUST BE
OUT OF HIS MIND IF HE THINKS
IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO SHIFT FUNDS
OUT OF FEMA FOR IMMIGRANT
DETENTION AT THE BORDER WHILE A
POTENTIAL CATEGORY THREE
HURRICANE BEARS DOWN ON THE
UNITED STATES.
FLORIDA IS A CRITICAL STATE IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S REELECTION
BID, TO BE SURE.
HE ALSO OWNS A LOT OF PROPERTY
THERE.
BUT SOME OF THE ATTACKS AGAINST
HIM APPEARED WAY OUT-OF-BOUNDS
BY CANADA'S FORMER
PRIME MINISTER KIM CAMPBELL WHO
HELD OFFICE FOR FOUR MONTHS
TWEETING, I'M ROOTING FOR A
DIRECT HIT ON MAR-A-LAGO.
AFTER SHE WAS PUMMELED ONLINE
FOR THAT TWEET, KANDEL CAME BACK
TO SAY I HAVE DELETED MY TWEET
ABOUT THE HURRICANE AND
MAR-A-LAGO AND SINCERELY
APOLOGIZE.
IT WAS INTENDED AS SARCASM, NOT
A SERIOUS WISH OF HARM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPENDING
TOMORROW EVENING AT CAMP DAVID.
HE'LL BE BACK SUNDAY WITH
MEETINGS WITH HIS NATIONAL
SECURITY AND FEMA TEAM ABOUT THE
HURRICANE WITH THIS CATEGORY
THREE STORM BEARING DOWN IN
FLORIDA.
THE PRESIDENT REALLY HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO CANCEL HIS VISIT
THE POLE WITH THEM.
HE  HE SAID IN THE SOUTH LAWN HE
HE  HE SAID IN THE SOUTH LAWN HL
SCHEDULE THAT FOR A LATER DATE,
MADE PAIR THAT WITH A VISIT TO
GERMANY.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO TALKS ABOUT